AND FOR PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IT'S
PERSONAL.
MORE OF MY EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH HIM.
>> WHEN YOU HEAR VLADIMIR PUTIN
TALK ABOUT THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT AS BEING FULL OF
NEO-NAZIS, AS SOMEBODY WHO IS OF
JEWISH DESCENT, HOW DO YOU REACT
TO THOSE STATEMENTS?
>> WELL, THERE ARE RARE
OCCASIONS WHEN I SMILE AND WHEN
I LAUGH, AND FOR ME TO HEAR IT
IT'S AS IF SOMETHING --
SOMETHING SIMILAR TO A JOKE.
I CANNOT TAKE THIS STATEMENT
SERIOUSLY.
UPON HEARING THE SITUATION --
HEARING THE STATEMENTS AT FIRST,
YOU JUST THINK TO YOURSELF THAT
THIS PERSON HAS BEEN IN A
LEADERSHIP POSITION FOR SO MANY
YEARS AND THIS PERSON IS
SUPPOSED TO HAVE A VERY CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE ARE BECAUSE OF THE SOVIET
LEGACY, BUT I THINK THAT
CURRENTLY PUTIN IS IN AN
INFORMATION BUBBLE.
I THINK THIS IS INFORMATION
BUNKER AND IT IS SO -- IT IS SO
POWERFUL, THIS BUNKER OF
INFORMATION, THAT HE REALLY
THINKS THAT UKRAINIANS ARE
NEO-NAZIS.
SO THIS IS A LAUGHABLE STATEMENT
FOR ME, AND A STRIKE OF FEAR
RESURFACES.
I'M NOT AFRAID OF ANYTHING
EXCEPT FOR PEOPLE, BUT THE
FACT -- THE FACT IS THAT IF HE
IS SERIOUS ABOUT THIS STATEMENT
HE MIGHT BE CAPABLE OF VERY
HORRENDOUS STEPS BECAUSE THAT
WOULD MEAN THAT THIS IS NOT A
GAME FOR HIM.
IF HE REALLY BELIEVES IN THIS,
IF IT'S NOT A GAME, THEN WE WILL
JUST CONTINUE FIGHTING AGAINST
IT.
IF IT'S A GAME.
BUT IF IT'S NOT A GAME, IF HE'S
SERIOUS ABOUT IT, IF HE THINKS
THAT THIS IS HIS MISSION TO
CONQUER OUR TERRITORY AND IF HE
SEES SIGNS OF NEO-NAZIS IN OUR
COUNTRY THEN MANY QUESTIONS
EMERGE ABOUT WHAT ELSE HE IS
CAPABLE OF DOING FOR THE SAKE OF
HIS AMBITIONS, FOR THE SAME OF
HIS MISSION.
SO THIS IS WHAT GIVES RISE TO A
FEELING WHICH IS NOT VERY
PLEASANT AND WHICH IS VERY
FRIGHTENING, VERY HAZARDOUS.
THAT IT CAN'T BE AN INFORMATION
BUBBLE WHICH WILL CONTINUE TO
EXERT PRESSURE AND IT WILL
PRESSURE RISE PUTIN TO FURTHER
ESCALATION.
>> CAN I ASK YOU SOMETHING ABOUT
YOUR FAMILY HISTORY?
YOUR GRANDFATHER SIMON SIEMIAN
IS THE ONLY SURVIVOR OUT OF THE
HOLOCAUST IN WORLD WAR II.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
AND WHAT WAS THE LESSON, WHAT
ARE THE VALUES YOU DREW FROM IT
WHEN YOU WOULD HEAR THOSE
STORIES IN YOUR FAMILY?
>> Translator: WELL, MY
GRANDFATHER AND HIS FOUR
BROTHERS WERE LIVING IN AN
ORDINARY VILLAGE AND THEN THE
SECOND WORLD WAR STARTED.
MY GRANDFATHER WAS GRADUATING
FROM MILITARY COLLEGE AT THAT
TIME AND ALL OF HIS BROTHERS
WENT TO WAR BECAUSE THEIR FATHER
SAID THAT THEY HAD TO PROTECT
THE COUNTRY.
THEY HAD TO FIGHT FASCISM.
SO THEY WENT TO WAR AND ALL THE
BROTHERS DIED, AND MY
GRANDFATHER SURVIVED THE ENTIRE
WAR.
HIS FATHER AND HIS MOTHER WERE
KILLED IN A TERRIBLE FIRE, THE
NAZIS SET ABLAZE THE ENTIRE
VILLAGE WHERE THEY LIVED AND
WHERE MY GRANDFATHER WAS BORN.
ALL THE BROTHERS -- ALL THE
BROTHERS PERISHED IN THE FRONT
LINE, HE WAS ALONE TO BE LEFT
STANDING.
HE RETURNED HOME.
HE ENDED UP IN THE CITY WHERE I
WAS BORN.
HE WAS A CAPTAIN OF AN INFANTRY
UNIT.
HE WAS AWARDED WITH A NUMBER OF
MILITARY ORDERS LIKE A RED
CROSS, LIKE A RED STAR FOR HIS
HEROISM AND HIS BRAVERY.
HE WAS WOUNDED AT WAR AND AFTER
THE WAR HE STARTED WORKING AS AN
INVESTIGATOR CATCHING CRIMINALS
AND EVENTUALLY HE BECAME A
COLONEL IN INDEPENDENT UKRAINE.
SO THAT IS HIS -- BASICALLY HIS
LIFE STORY.
SO WHEN RUSSIANS ARE TELLING
ABOUT NEO-NAZIS AND THEY TURN TO
ME, I JUST REPLIED THAT I HAVE
LOST MY ENTIRE FAMILY IN THE WAR
BECAUSE ALL OF THEM WERE
EXTERMINATED DURING WORLD WAR
II.
A NUMBER OF MY DISTANT RELATIVES
ARE STILL -- ARE STILL LIVING,
SOME OF THEM ARE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND POLAND OR IN ISRAEL.
THAT IS WHAT I KNOW.
SO BASICALLY THAT IS ALL.
SO NAZIISM IN OUR FAMILY EVOKES
A HUGE AMOUNT OF
MISUNDERSTANDING.
SO WE DO NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT, WHAT
KIND OF NAZIS IN THE COUNTRY?
WE FOUGHT A WAR WITH THESE
PEOPLE, NAZIS.
SO I HAVE A QUESTION FOR RAISING
THE TOPICS OF NAZIS FROM THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION.
I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM THERE --
FROM THEM AND WHAT FRONT LINES
THAT THEIR GRANDFATHERS FOUGHT,
WHAT COUNTRIES THEIR
GRANDFATHERS LIBERATED, HOW
THEIR GRANDFATHERS FOUGHT IN
NAZI GERMANY.
I HAVE THIS QUESTION TO THEM.
WHEN SOME POLITICIANS IN RUSSIAN
FEDERATION ARE RAISING THIS
TOPIC OF NEO-NAZIISM, OF NAZIISM
AND FASCISM RELATED TO ME I HAVE
A QUESTION THAT, WELL, MY
BIOGRAPHY IS OPEN AND EVERYONE
IS WELL AWARE ABOUT MY
BIOGRAPHY.
YOU CAN FIND FACTS ABOUT MY
FAMILY IN OPEN SOURCES, BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE RELATIVES OF RUSSIANS?
I DO NOT KNOW ABOUT ANYTHING
ABOUT THEIR RELATIVES OR
RUSSIANS WHO FOUGHT IN THE
SECOND WORLD WAR WHO ARE TALKING
ABOUT NEO-NAZIISM.
THE ENTIRE TERRITORY OF UKRAINE
WAS OCCUPIED.
THE NAZI REGIME OCCUPIED THE
ENTIRE TERRITORY OF UKRAINE AND
UKRAINE FOUGHT AGAINST NAZIS.
BY THE WAY, IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN,
MORE THAN 70 DAYS WE RESISTED
THE OFFENSIVE OF NAZIS, THE WAY
IT IS FIGHTING NOW, IT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN FIGHTING FOR MANY
DAYS -- FOR MANY DAYS IT WAS
REPELLING THE ATTACKS, IT WAS A
GREAT BATTLE.
MANY PEOPLE WERE DEAD, BUT STILL
THEY CONTINUED THEIR RESISTANCE
AND I KNOW MANY PEOPLE IN RUSSIA
WHO ARE OCCUPIED AND WHO
STRUGGLED AGAINST HITLER'S
REGIME, BUT KYIV WAS OCCUPIED
AND MOSCOW WAS NOT.
YOU CANNOT SAY -- YOU CANNOT
JUST -- THEY CANNOT JUST SAY
ABOUT THEIR FEELINGS THAT
UKRAINE IS A BETRAYER OR WE ARE
NEO-NAZIS BECAUSE RUSSIANS ARE
ACTING IN THE SAME MATTER AS
NEO-NAZIS AT THE MOMENT.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
HISTORY AND SCIENTIFIC MATERIALS
YOU CAN JUST LOOK AT WHAT NAZIS
DID, THEY BLOCKADED KYIV, THEY
BLOCKADED OTHER CITIES TO
PREVENT THE SUPPLIES OF WATER
AND FOOD, AND THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT RUSSIANS ARE DOING NOW.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE DOING IN
MARIUPOL, THEY ARE -- THEY ARE
JUST GOING TO THE CITY SAYING
THAT EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE
ALL RIGHT AND THAT THIS IS
RUSSIAN TERRITORY, THEY'RE JUST
CLAIMING IT.
THEIR METHODS HAVE REMAINED
UNCHANGED.
THE FACT IS THAT THEY ARE
BETRAYING THE HISTORY OF THEIR
OWN HOMELAND BECAUSE WHAT WE ARE
HAVING NOW IN MARIUPOL, IN KYIV,
THEY HAD THE SAME IN LENNON GRAD
WHICH IS NOW ST. PETERSBURG,
FORMERLY KNOWN ADDS LINEN GRAD.
EVERYONE KNO